q il s'agit d'arriver à la vérité où nous
allons un
[Musique]
ils nous appellent une secte nous ne sommes pas une secte
quel magasin mr.  le président Donald Trump
a été choisi par les chefs militaires pour se présenter
à la présidence afin de faire
tomber l'État profond
[Musique]
nous ne savons pas exactement qui Chu est d'accord
Joo n'est pas une seule personne d'accord Q est un groupe
de personnes là-bas  l'intérieur aux
gentils et ils connaissent la véritable histoire, ce qui
se passe et il s'agit de
mettre fin à l'État profond.
[Musique]
nous avons eu plus de 3 500 messages de ce groupe
de ce que je crois être des renseignements militaires
proches de la présidence qui ont créé  une
sorte de moyen numérique populaire
d'éduquer les Patriotes en
leur posant simplement des questions
[Musique]
implique toute la force spatiale et une
éventuelle vie extraterrestre comme les pédophiles que vous
connaissez et elle cherche juste à lier tout
cela ensemble
[Musique]
oh mon garçon
ces 17 fois plus rapides que le missile le plus rapide,
donc je pense que j'aurais pu
être à Washington 17 fois dans ma
vie
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
où nous allons un jour  allez, nous y allons, vous
savez, le général Flynn, il révélait beaucoup
de secrets de l'État profond, c'est
pourquoi il était une cible, donc vous savez que
nous soutenons le général Flynn.
[Musique]